[Music]
today's question comes from robert in
virginia i'm 40 years old working for
the government earning 80 000 but i
absolutely hate it
don't be unclear robert i don't know why
we're laughing i'm sorry that we're
amused by that it's just his phrasing
you can feel it you can feel it popping
off the page i hate my job that's right
uh he's been there for 15 years and he
says i cannot break into management
they've promoted someone with no
experience or education over me a couple
of years ago i've always wanted to get
into tech and coding but i know those
jobs don't initially pay as much as i
make now
i'm gonna push back on that one
momentarily i have about a hundred
thousand dollars in debt if i left my
job and took my pension i would receive
eighty five thousand dollars and have
another twenty thousand in an ira this
would give me the opportunity to be debt
free and start fresh should i quit and
start fresh or stay where it's safe and
keep trying to chip away at the debt so
number one don't stay where you are
because you already are resenting this
current place of employment you've been
overlooked and that's very personal to
you and so you're going to decay your
soul will decay if you stay now before
you quit though i want you to get
qualified
and i endorse a wonderful organization
called bethel tech it's a nine month
program
you can cash flow your way through it
and they are having students starting at
68 to 70 000 a year that's slightly
below what you make but dave if he's got
the uh uh the 85k and the 20k and the
ira i'll let you address that on the
debt so nine months he becomes a dev one
that's exactly right now he's on his way
and you're talking about one is a 70 to
80k right now yep that's right and um
you step into that and then you step out
uh but the good news is if you'll
continue to develop those code skills
and move from to dev2 to f3 let's start
learning platform start learning some of
the other things that are out there in
the tech world continue to grow in that
that you know we got guys in this
building they're making a couple hundred
grand that's correct
lots of them yes programmers are still
in demand software engineer is a big
deal
and so um uh the the market is going to
get more competitive there it's been a
um
it's been kind of a
employees market uh for the last little
while
and uh
but it's
a lot of this recession is slowing
things down we're going to see some of
these developers on the street that's
correct and um so but yeah but i still
would go do this yeah so stay in the
government job
he can to bethel tech while he's got a
full-time job absolutely okay you're
doing it online that's where all their
students do it's a nine-month program by
the way they give ramsey show listeners
a discount off of the fifteen thousand
so uh i got to spend some time with the
guys wonderful founder of that a while
back they're good people yeah well we're
seeing great results we're seeing people
that are uh starting jobs in the 75 80
000 range uh they're casual
we're using them too we are to to put to
fill some of our developer needs that's
right as well so um
you know internally so in addition to
they became an advertiser on your show
but they're good they're good guys and
that's a valid thing yeah go to code
school dude yes definitely definitely
get out of the state job but do not quit
until you're qualified and then you got
something else to step onto i just
always want to make sure people hear
we're not a big fan of jumping off a
cliff
that's right this time next year you're
in the new job yeah and uh the debt free
can be debt free would you advise that
though dave on the uh cashing out of the
pension no pay off his debt no you're
going to roll that pension that's what i
thought into a 401k or into an ira yeah
uh to keep from having the taxes on it
and the penalties and everything no you
don't want to do that you want to cash
it out but uh but you can you can work
your way through the debt we just got to
get you where you're not miserable first
and um
that's the thing and
lots lots of opportunity there